You are liars and you shouldn't be here.
You don't believe in anything you say
and you try to hurt people who call you
out in your
>> but Destiny and Dan unfortunately in my
opinion they're acting like they have a
headsh shot against Jtock Queen and
schizophrenic community members and I
don't think they do.
>> You've literally doxed multiple people
you unbelievable
embarrassing.
What the is wrong with you?
You please just explain the situation.
Okay, so there is a clipping Discord
that I'm a part of. Okay, I will ask for
links to stuff. Uh, I will suggest clips
to people. I'll retweet other people's
clips, right? Basically, they're trying
to post like cut up logs with absent any
context as if this is like an evil
doxing server. Destiny wants this to go
and flow into his greater narrative that
I'm running like a cabal that's been
working against him, that hates him, and
wants to undermine everything he's ever
done. Shimu and the Candros caught using
doxing tools to unmask anonymous ex
users in the snark discord. Leaked logs
show discussion on using doxing tools,
tracking username history, and trying to
pressure anonymous accounts into
revealing personal information before
the conversation moved to private
channels. Anyone know how to gay them
into revealing more info? Run the docs
tool. What's the docs tool exactly?
>> Well, well, well. Diddy Dan and Epstein
desperately trying to smear me as some
kind of docker or something with some
redacted thing of a public only fans
person. Novaru is another friend of
Tekone who lives in uh Texas which is
public on their Twitter. So you redacted
that to make it look like I was doxing
their location, but it's public on their
Twitter. You slimy piece of [__]
>> Is the log you redacted? So you redacted
the the username that's redacted was in
these logs. Yes.
>> The username in these logs, you redacted
it and said it was different to the
Twitter username. It's not, is it?
>> Uh, okay. Yeah, the Steam name here is
the same as that one. Yes.
>> Okay. So, you were wrong or lying
earlier, weren't you, Dan?
>> Uh, my bad. They they reentered the same
username twice to get email. Like, if
you want, as I said before,
>> so they were using a single username. I
mean, one username was posted in there.
They didn't post the docs tool. They
didn't run the docs tool.
>> They did post the doc. They post they
post twerlock and archiver. They did not
post law archive. They mentioned it.
>> Yes, they did. Oh. Oh, sorry. They
mentioned it. Okay.
>> Answer my question.
>> Looking people up.
>> What are you accusing Shimu of? Answer
my question now.
>> I'm trying to find the actual real life
identity of an anonymous Twitter account
and then being and then being able to
send it off.
>> Trying to find or trying to dox. Trying
to find or trying to dox.
>> Oh, sorry. Trying to dox the identity
off of a username.
>> Okay. So, where's So, you think Shimu
was trying to publish it? That's what
you think? For the purpose of
harassment? Well, I mean, uh, could be.
I have no idea. He said he hated the
person, right?
>> Nice one, you. You have no idea. Nice
one, you [__] sneaky little.
>> With that being said, I think we're on
to the Connor stuff now. Finally, we're
on our way. We can head on over to it.
The Connor stuff. The the issue is the
you are finding people that you perceive
to be as not in your team on this
whatever this is and then you are
leveraging every single asset and weapon
you can to hunt this person down and
then to try to split them off by
engaging in like multiple levels of
harassment to to break them away from
whatever person you're
>> okay this is more of a tangible
allegation that's what he's saying we're
doing I guess that's what he's saying
this Discord is doing
>> going after that's really the issue um
everybody has no feelings on [__]
personally I wouldn't fix it on the
doxing part I don't give a doxing part
the issue is the this hyper fixated um
hypercoordinated
this. What you're highlighting right now
is not that even a little bit. What
you're highlighting right now is these
two being having an investment in the
techone story and trying to help Pink
understand that there's somebody
harassing her who is directly involved
with Teone. That's not what's happening.
What the thing you're circling is not
that. He's like going back to what he
thinks me and Queen are doing to him,
right? And trying to say this is an
example of that. It's not. It's not even
remotely close to that. are you talking
about, dog? How How is anybody getting
broken off? What the are you talking
about, man? Top down mediated harassment
campaign against people. This is wild.
It's insane. But what about the argument
that you're responding to doxing with
doxing? For that, you have to have
either I have to be there to have the
conversation or you need to have like a
strong person. I have to be there to
Don't argue this at all, guys. Don't
argue this at all. Don't Don't guys
don't go and argue that I should be able
to dox people. I It looks embarrassing.
>> My first question is always like, "Oh my
god, did you hear that A did this crazy
to B?" My first question is always like,
"Oh, what did B do? Why did A do that?
What was going on there?" You know,
because Yeah. So, just be very accurate
about what A did and then say you doxed
in response to it. But the problem is
you couldn't do that. That's why you had
to lie about it. It's why you had to say
that Queen and I were involved in Kiwi
Farms and we were like getting you guys
doxed and swatted and all of this. It's
why you consistently did this because if
you actually just said what we did, you
would look deranged because you are
deranged.
>> A could be a horrible, terrible,
malicious actor or B could have had it
coming. Really depends on what's going
on, you know. Yeah. But the but but the
the frustrating thing too is that um
these actors like Connor or Wick or
whatever. I don't know if they just
don't understand it or they don't care
or whatever, but the people that I'm
arguing with do do understand it and
they will make those arguments um for
ethical doxing, right? Which which is
what happens later on in this video is
when they realize like, okay, well, hold
on. Is all doxing bad? Well, if it's a
person that's harassing, the thing we've
been saying this whole time, the thing I
brought up with Aerodite was I need a
specific allegation I can respond to.
Otherwise, you're just leaning into this
and saying I'm doxing people and opening
me up to being harassed or being doxed
in response. You are you are basically
putting a massive target on me. I've
been asking for what is this specific
allegation? What did I do? Instead of
subtly supporting Desi's baseless
accusations, you directly accuse me
publicly or privately of what you're
implying here so you can actually defend
myself. There is no allegation. I have
not been alleged to have done anything
specific.
And they're saying it was okay to me.
There is no evidence for anything
they've alleged in terms of my conduct.
They've created like they've tried to
make it so I'm like Schroinger's doxer.
I'm both a docer and not a doxer until
you can prove otherwise until you can
observe. But Destiny won't let anyone
observe. And so somehow and I I know
how. It's just the clout. It's just the
money. It's just the capability of like
leeching off of his audience. That's the
only reason people aren't like, "Yeah,
we should just look in the box." What's
in the box, man? What's in the box? But
they don't want to look in the box. And
I think it's I I think at this point to
me to be honest with you, the the piling
on the perpetuating the narratives
without being willing to look in the box
or say that it has to be considered
false. Destiny is a liar until he can
show anything he said.
The refusal to do that is disqualifying
for politics for all these people. They
are too disingenuous. They are too
self-involved. They are liars. and they
will warp their own opinions or feelings
on the world for money and clout over
anything. They have disqualified
themselves from being political
commentators. You have to look at at
whatever the evidence is and say you are
deranged or not. When he refuses to show
you, when he says, "Oh, I'll show you
after my case." [__] you. And if this
was happening to any of you, I would be
standing up against it. I would be you.
Listen, it was I I was too much of a
when it was Sunday, okay? I was too much
of a but even I said hey that was never
do that again. Hey what the you guys you
you can't be shocked if people are going
to call you a doxing community. If Dan's
going to come on my stream and say the
name of some Hassan editor cuz he hates
him. And if you're going to come on my
stream and try to drop President
Sunday's name, you cannot be upset or
confused when people call you a doxing
community. And that was that wasn't
strong enough. I should have taken a
stronger stance than that.
But none of these people could even do
that. It seems like none of these people
would say anything along these lines at
all. Very sad. And Pinky Chu, who was a
victim of assault, and we need to get
this information in order to help out
Pikachu, right? Isn't it good? Whoa.
Whoa. So, okay, maybe it is. Maybe
there's a time and a place for where
having an identification of a person is
actually like a worthwhile thing, you
know. So, you know, if you ask So,
Destiny went beyond just having if
Destiny had looked up this information
and kept it in his back pocket in case
he wanted to file a subpoena later.
Nobody would be calling him a doxer,
right? That's not doxing. You found that
information. You hired a private eye to
go and look into these people. You found
out where they lived and you wanted to
serve them with papers.
No wrongdoing has occurred. Now, you
publish it online to with them
explicitly. You posted on websites that
are meant to facilitate real life harm
on people. Now you're deranged. Now
you're out of your mind.
Why are we why would we pretend
otherwise? Ask people, why have you guys
doxed Destiny? Why did you guys dox
these people? You know, what is your
goal for doing it on their side? It's
because he said something I don't like
or he was mean to somebody I don't like
or that I do like or he has a political
opinion I just I don't even know
actually what their I don't know what
the rationals they give for any of these
people are. I have to go in and look at
>> um listen for the for the cyber one I
think it's like total I think he's
obviously lying right
>> for people that I've been involved with
this with it was because they were spam
copy pasting uh insanely disgusting
attacks against the girl that I was
debating from all
>> so the story here is he now hangs out in
a discord with Kelly and the person the
other person who is spamming these
attacks
this is like totally disingenuous
obvious obviously like lying that this
is his line. He hangs out with those
people now. He's in a Discord with those
people. Why would everybody who actually
disagreed on this, who said, "No, no,
no, no, no. This is wrong." Why would we
be held responsible? By the way, Lena,
the girl he was dating, messaged me
directly and said, "Thank you for saying
that that was not okay. I really
appreciate you standing up for me."
That's what she said to me.
So, the idea that this was a And by the
way, I said, "Hey, if you could like
chill him out on the doxing stuff in in
return, I would really appreciate that
because I'm pretty concerned about it."
From another thread that it wasn't her
thread, but it was somebody else's
thread for a person that she dated. And
they were spamming those attacks into
Justic's Discord via Kelly Gene often
times. And they were using that to
attack uh my girlfriend at the time
because they thought that it was
disgusting that she hadn't publicly
disavowed me and left me. Yeah. Kelly
Kelly was saying this and I was
repeatedly saying that's not okay.
That's not cool. Show me any evidence of
other people jumping on these attacks
and going with that. Except for Kelly
and I think Shelby, right? I think it
was. Everybody else in the Discord was
like, "This is disgusting. Off." I on
the stream say, "This is disgusting.
Off." No, you don't do collateral
attacks. You don't do that. You don't
know what that person's opinion is. You
don't attack them for not disavowing
Destiny unless they basically have given
you some standard. Unless she came out
and said something like, "Oh, if this
comes out to be true, I disavow." Right.
Unless she did that, you have no reason
to do it.
>> So, the issue with people like Connor
and Wick is they're too to see the
difference between these scenarios.
They're like, "Well, it's still all the
same." It's really not if you're not a
you don't care about the Kelly thing.
You don't even care about Lena. Like,
it's you're obviously lying when you say
you care about Lena. You're just
obviously full of
It's really not the same at all. But
like, they just don't understand. So,
these are like He hung out on a stream
with Kelly, by the way, like a month
ago. Two months ago. He was just hanging
out on a stream with her. Was he going
the whole time? It's so disgusting that
you attacked my girlfriend like this.
Did he do that? Or maybe I missed it.
Maybe I missed him going like, "You're a
totally disgusting, disingenuous piece
of Kelly. I hate you. I hate you." Cuz
he he justified coming after me, the
person who was against that, who said
that was bad, who had a whole discord
who said that was bad. And then he hangs
out with Kelly after that. Very weird.
>> Again, it's always the worst when you
have the people in the center that you
have to go through to to demonstrate the
insanity of the other side because they
play this like, "Well, I think that it's
all bad." And it's like, "Okay, yeah, me
It would be cool if nobody was doing
this kind of behavior. But that's sound
a little
>> I mean it sounds bad, but I need more
context to understand what Aandress was
getting at. Yes. I'd like to hear a
response as to you know what what is
what is he looking to get out of it and
what is the gayop exactly?
>> Can you spin uh can you spin an example
where this would be except what is a
gaps? I honestly don't understand. Gabs
is the internet slang version of
astroturfing. So gaps would be um I know
that Connor is streaming today. I really
want Connor to hate Destiny. So, I'm
going to make an account called um for
bro fester hit squad DGG and I'm going
to go on to Conor's chat and I'm going
to type things like um don't you think
that uh don't you think that Destiny was
right when you said that monogous
relationship suck and that's why you got
divorced? Like wasn't it'll be like
stuff like that to where the content
creator will see it. He associates it
with DG.
>> So, hold on. Is this like what? Wait,
what? Hold on. Hold on.
Is the internet slang version of
astroturfing? So gaps would be um I know
that Connor is streaming today. I really
want Connor to hate Destiny. So I'm
gonna make an account called um for Bro
Hit Squad DG and I'm gonna go on to
Conor's chat and I'm going to type
things like um don't you think that uh
don't you think that Destin was right
when he said the monogous relationship
suck and that's why you got divorced?
Like wasn't it'll be like stop. Did this
get coordinated somewhere?
I This just sounds weird. Like I would
just be like that's weird. That's weirdo
behavior. Why you doing that? I is he
just inventing stuff? He's just creative
writing. What are we doing, man? Stuff
like that to where the content creator
will see it. He associates it with DG or
with me and then they get these opinions
over time. This is what gaps. It's
astroturfing. It's creating other
accounts to go in and mislead people
about where you're from and then to kind
of uh subtly inject your ideas or your,
you know, whatever you want that
community's kind of understanding of a
thing to be. That's what gaps are. Chad
absolutely knows what gaps is. Every
single person that's operated in these
spaces for the past decade absolutely
knows what gaps is. Everybody does. He's
had stream titles in the past that know
what Gabs is. That's why everyone should
be required to be identified on the
internet and to relink their SSN every
week to all. I mean, I don't necessarily
think that's true. I just think if you
make it your whole life online to harass
and abuse other people, I think it's
worth it to know who you are. I think
your name should be tied to that. I
don't think you should be allowed to
engage in that type of behavior forever
and then be able to walk away from it
because you're bored. I don't think so.
So like when esports Batman wants to tie
his like reputation as a lawyer into
making claims about the legality of
>> You don't actually believe this. If you
believe this, you wouldn't let actual
lawyers come into your under pseudonyms.
By the way, I totally don't want that. I
don't want that. That would be
disgusting. But he's obviously lying
here of my court case or whatever. Then
I think it's I think it's okay for
people to want to know like, well, who
is this person? Like that should be I
think it's okay to want to know. It's
not okay to publish it because you want
to harass them away from the space. That
is what's not okay, you lying,
disingenuous worm, tied to your
professional reputation. You're staking
your professional reputation on it, on
your legal conclusions or your legal
analyses. So, why wouldn't people have a
right to know who you are, right? I the
idea that you could um you know,
credential yourself in such a way and
then run away from who you are is that's
insane to me.
>> Where did he run away to?
There's no running away. You just wanted
to harass the guy away. That's the only
goal here, right? If you thought he was
doing something improper, you could have
without doxing. Again, this is the
problem. There is a thing happening here
where Destiny tries to say, "Well, I had
to dox because the public had a right to
know his name." One, no. And two, if he
was doing something improper, you could
have found his identity and reported him
in a way that to say, "Hey, I think what
this guy is doing is improper."
You could have done that.
But you didn't do that. You just
published it because you were trying to
harass them. It's just like when he when
he talks about like why he went after me
or anyone else, he could have if he he
said, by the way, what he said
originally as well was he wanted to
serve me with a lawsuit. He's never
attempted to serve me with a lawsuit.
Okay? He said he wanted to do that. If
he actually wanted to do that, he would
not have published any information he
found, right? He would have just served
a lawsuit.
You are lying. You're just lying, man.
Um, so he just made that made it clear.
It isn't the standard, it's the fact
that the analysis is not in his favor.
Exactly. Yes. It's But it's not even
that. Dustin Suggs, I truly believe that
he's just such a small, petty,
vindictive person that realistically his
dox targets aren't people who are just
discussing his case. They're not the
people with the worst opinions of him.
They're just people who he used to know
who don't like him anymore.
That's that's the most offensive. That's
why he picked esports Batman and Wicked
Supreme.
That's why those were the people he went
after. It's because Supreme's, by the
way, he posted a screenshot of what he
said he was doxing Supreme for. It's
something like this guy is just like
kind of a sad, weird little man that is
like crashing out. That's essentially
what he do Supreme for. That's it. He
posted a screenshot of like what set him
off when he was going to do it. And it's
literally like, uh, Dusty, he just seems
like a really sad person who's lonely
and just wants his friends to like pay
attention to him. And it just feels a
little weird to me. Like it's it's
really sad watching what's happened.
Just accurate accurate cutting analysis
from somebody he used to respect hurts
him more than anything in the world.
Destiny, but can't they argue that this
is what they were trying to do? I don't
understand what you I don't know what
you mean. Like you can you can say that
if you want, but I um I mean like
there's a fact of the matter at the end
of the day that we can talk about,
right? Like I don't I don't obsessively
um stalk and harass. Dude, there's I'm
not even going to film on it. Just just
if any of you were ever in DGG, the
number of times he has laughed his ass
off. The number of times he has totally
discredited Hassan or Vosch for saying
that his community and him stalk them,
right? And he says, "That's cuz you just
don't want to deal with the criticism.
That's cuz you don't want to deal. I'm
just watching your public your public
streams. I'm just watching your public
content. And he's totally flipped on
this 180 completely. It's so
embarrassing, dude.
Everything he once preached, he is
turned against. He is just a whiny who
doesn't have any principles, who's
totally falling apart and go over the
personal lives of all these people every
single like I don't do. The whole reason
why um the whole reason why Justical
even became popular as a streamer is
because I was so disinterested in all
drama content that I just offshored all
of it to the after hours to just stream
cuz I I just had no desire to do this
type of like super enter.
>> You watch the stream constantly. You're
just lying right now. You watch the You
engage in it constantly. What are you
saying? What are you talking about, man?
>> Personal drama. It just wasn't it just
wasn't part of my content anymore. And
it really right when I first started he
came in and was like fighting with the
women posting. We had like not safe for
work channel. There were women women
posting nudes in that discord. People
who had relationships with him by the
way and like it was a whole massive
drama that was within 3 months of the
community starting what are we talking
about man? [__] we talking about truly
he just wanted a fake separation. He
didn't want to not have drama. He just
wanted this fake separation so that he
could push it away from him and pretend
that it wasn't there because he wanted
to do he wanted the political clout
without dropping all the drama. And
let's be real, like the fact that people
will like get really invested in the
content and he's got like a pool of fans
to that's what he didn't want to get rid
of, right? He wanted the pool of fans to
but also to be a serious political
creator. And now he's posting weird
screenshots of himself in a bed at 3:00
am to me and a bunch of people are like
quote tweeting that and going, "Dude,
what the is wrong with this guy?" That's
where he's at now. Okay. Very different,
very different place in life at this
point. Um, what would you say to the
people defending you who are concerned
about being doxed retributively for
defending your doxing? I mean, like it
sucks, but I mean that's what these
people do. I mean, they they'll dox
everybody around me. Like, they already
do. They were dxing random chatters of
mine a year ago to try to get people to
um this is any evidence that this is
tied to me again. We're here again.
We're here. So when he says, "Oh no,
these guys are like deranged." I'm just
looking for any evidence, man. Any
evidence at all.
There just hasn't been any evidence, no
evidence shown that I have anything to
do with that. And I can cover your
content. That's the way this all works.
I'm just covering your stream. Stop
seething about it.
>> Dissociate with my community. Yeah.
Force you to do anything. Okay. We I
there you don't have to if you want to
give an answer maybe two hours and 17
minutes
a case of frolicking going on. I feel
like this term helps explain a lot of
behavior especially that of big content
creators who bully and harass smaller
streamers. Narcissistic rage is a sudden
intense outburst of anger or aggressive
behavior or cold weaponized silence
displayed by someone with narcissistic
traits. It is triggered by a
narcissistic injury, a perceived slight
criticism or boundary that threatens
their fragile ego and shatters their
illusion of superiority. Understanding
this phenomenon involves recognizing its
roots, manifestations, and strategies
for protection. The frolicker POV
frolicer POV right now. Root causes
triggering shame. It stems from an
underlying deep-seated fear of being
found out flawed. Found out flawed or
inadequate. The narcissistic injury.
Anything that challenges their
grandiosity or sense of entitlement acts
as a severe blow to their superficial
self-image. Loss of control. When they
can no longer manipulate a situation or
get the consistent admiration they feel
entitled to, they lash out as a defense
mechanism to regain dominance. Common
manifest manifestations, explosive
outbursts, loud, disproportionate, and
often terrifying fits of rage involving
screaming threats and aggressive
gestures, passive aggression, simmering
resentment. There's like a rumor, and
this is totally rumor, by the way. It's
not I I have no way to prove it, but I
have heard that when Desi Molina had
like their final argument that he picked
up her phone and like threw it at the
wall.
Now, is that is that even something that
I would say like is outside of any
relationship? No, but it's just funny.
It's just like a funny thing.
I bet you he didn't even put a hole IN
THE DRYWALL, MAN. IT'S LIKE TRUMP
throwing the tendies at the wall, you
know? similar levels of report of
reporting reliability. You know, Trump
throwing the tendies at the wall, Desi
throwing the phone at the wall. Very
similar. I I can't say I believe it
happened. Okay. I Well, certainly
nothing in his character would lead me
to believe that it didn't happen, but I
just I think it's like um somebody told
me this happened. I have no way to prove
it or no. Passive aggression, simmering
resentment, deliberate neglect, cutting
sarcasm, or weaponized silent treatment
or to control and punish others.
Blameshifting. The refusal to take
responsibility, often resulting in them
accusing you of causing their anger. Oh
my god. Oh my god. Blameshifting. Like
you got a deranged war with skitsos on
Kiwi farms cuz you were a loser with no
actual like attachment to any other
person and so you just fought with
somebody on a forum, right? And then
after it came out that you were a
disgusting freak, right? That you were a
consent violating pervert. After that
came out, you decided that I was to
blame for it. Oh my god, it explains all
of it.
And now my my tendrils have shifted from
just snarking destiny to ruining all of
American politics. The top three threats
to the American political way of life
are in order. Trump, then the MAGA
movement, then Jtock. Okay, these are
the big three. The big three that we are
terrified of that will lead to the
destruction of democracy.
Truly, truly, truly. I'm just glad I
beat out Hassan. It's very funny. We're
We're back to this. Let's Let's check it
out.
>> And uh they use doxing tools, I think
they call it, but they're basically like
open source intelligence gathering tools
in order to try to find information on
an online account.
>> Uh-oh.
Is that going to like that that Connor
corrected open source intelligence
gathering tools is harassing Pikachu?
And I think the assertion that they make
wrong, I don't think that was true. who
I think it was just people that they
were beefing with is that they uh they
planned on if they actually found out
that person like let's say it was
techone or was a tectone community
member they were going to pass it on to
Pikachu or lawyers or whatever so she
could defend herself legally from these
people origally harassing her right in
Shaboo in Cros also this like thing of
like um I just I hate describing
>> it's just not like proven out by the
logs whatsoever
>> common sense things bro this actually
drives me crazy it's the least favorite
part of streaming where some of the
stuff people saying is so weird like I
feel like there's like a there's um
there's a moment in in like a TV show or
movie actually it happened in oh the
mockingb bird um am I misremembering
this for is Attakus Finch kind of like
this like lanky tall has glasses like
seems kind of like a meek man and that's
just kind of how everybody kind of views
him and then there was a I believe
people thought it was a rabid dog and
then he is like handed a rifle and he
goes like you know sightes up murder
mode like one shot oblivates his dog and
like the children are like oh dad's on
some wild does this happen or am I
making this up right
>> I don't know what the talking about man
>> I feel like sometimes these moment there
are these moments in movies or TV shows
where like something is happening and
then one of the characters like oh [__]
it looks like the zombies or somebody's
about to do this like let me take care
of and they do some crazy and everybody
else around is Wait a second. What the
[__] How the do you know that [__] For
Connor to like breeze over and maybe he
won't breeze over it. Okay. But for
Connor to breeze over Oh, well, there's
a person that was arresting Pikachu. So,
in their Discord, these guys went ahead
and they grabbed an Osent tool that used
to fully
>> Oh, I see what he's arguing. This is
like he's arguing that these guys are
like um they're kind of like Jason
Bourne, right? That they've got these
tools, this training. Of course, they
know to go to these tools cuz they want
to use these tools. Now, this is of
course completely defeated by just a
little bit of thinking cuz then if if
they could just think a little bit, why
would they basically be like, "Isn't
this website this one?" And like,
"Couldn't we It costs money, but like
could we look something up here?" So,
they know everything about the tools,
but they don't have subscriptions to
them or use them frequently enough that
they could just message somebody
directly. They're like pondering. Isn't
that kind of just defeated by the logs
outright that they use these tools
often? They didn't even have a
subscription. It cost money. They don't
even have a subscription.
people including hashes of leaked
passwords in the dark web or online uh
ordinary internet databases uh because
they're trying to protect Pikachu.
That's like
>> but they didn't ask for that
information. They weren't looking for
that.
>> I think that most people would say uh
how the even know about this tool like
the obvious assumption would be oh well
these guys are definitely like people
that have done this before. This this is
probably like an ordinary part of what
they do, right? Like if you if you would
go into a community that doesn't do this
and you were suggesting like this most
of the people would be like oh um that's
kind of weird or I've never used this. I
already know this is like isn't this a
lot or what would you like when it's
like okay guys I'll use this to like
okay yeah I'll forward it to whatever
we'll figure it out. Right. It's obvious
that this is ordinary behavior in the
community. I hate that I even have to
say this because this is just such an
obvious thing that any human being would
piece together immediately
>> are defending their honor with
>> Yeah. Again, it's just sort of defeated
by the fact that they had to ask. They
might be aware of it and they are
researchers, right? They are like again
this is like standard and commentary
research. Should they have been talking
about it in that place? No. But it's
absolutely standard in commentary
research.
in this argument saying like, "Yeah, we
might have engaged in an event doc or PI
operation or whatever the [__] you want
to call it, but we were doing so uh for
no reason and we did not have the
intention of publishing it, which is
technically the definition of doxing,
but the DGP people are saying like,
okay, you're still trying to find
something."
>> I'm kind of lost whether they have a
techone of all people because I think
techone I don't even remember why. Maybe
it was because Dan was talking to tech
like part of the enemy team. So the
enemy team being people who have done
really like bad basically like crimes,
you know, exposed minor to at a very
young age, right? They they've they've
done these kinds of bad things and the
majority of their content a very large
portion of the content is HSA is bad.
That's the core of the kilo document,
right? But also for Shimu, he just
identified that tectone was harmful.
Like a little ahead of the curve. And
for Nandros, he just didn't like Knucks.
Oh, what's up Bern? Thank you for the
500 kicks. With with Nandros and Shimu,
they had their own interest in the that
content before they were like
interacting with us. It was because the
content was so well done that we started
talking to them and hanging out with
them.
So like the reason they ended up in the
community is not because we all shared
the goal of with Destiny. It's hey these
guys are like good. They do good work.
They expose some wrongdoing over here.
Let's let's talk to those guys. Let's
see what they want to do. Let's see what
they're You guys got any thoughts on on
how this should be presented? You guys
got any thoughts on how you'd like
phrase this argument?
It's a meeting of the minds that they
don't like because those minds don't
have any investment in them.
We evaluate Destiny or Ethan or Techone
purely on their utility to the world and
we find all of these people lacking.
Okay, you are a negative. You are a net
negative not just to the world but to
the content creation space more
specifically. Do I care that you're a
net negative to the world? Not
particularly.
But you are harmful to the content
creation space. You are oppressive. You
are liars and you shouldn't be here. You
don't believe in anything you say and
you try to hurt people who call you out
in your youth. They will like go after
people around. I don't even I think I
literally think it was just because Dan
talked to him once on stream or
something. I don't I don't remember it
was something stupid like this. So that
like they had that feeling about him
that he was like part of the enemy team
which is technically the definition of
doxing but the GGG was like oh you're
still trying to find somebody's and
that's what we've been accusing of the
entire time.
>> Oh was oh okay the connection actually I
think that's probably right. It wasn't
the connection from Dan to Tech. It was
because techone was attacking Hassan.
That's probably it actually. Correct.
Sorry. These people are affiliated with
logic. They're affiliated with their own
schizophrenic communities. They're
affiliated with Queen and with Jto and
all that kind of stuff. So what Destiny
and Dan what they have accused Jto Queen
and schizophrenic community members of
the commentary community of doing is
harassing them digitally by finding
their personal identifiable information
and publishing it to the internet so
their family can be harassed so they can
be harassed and be swatted. So they say
haha
we have caught you in a private discord
using the tools that we know that you
used. But what JTO Queman and other
community members are saying is you
didn't catch us spec you didn't catch us
specifically. You have no evidence of us
specifically engaging in the bad
behavior. And in retaliation, you have
engaged in this bad behavior yourself
against us despite not having evidence
against us specifically. So the way that
I would say it also the bad behavior
from Destiny came before this Discord
even existed is the problem.
So it's like people who we didn't hang
out with when the Destiny stuff went
down that that Desi blamed me and Quid
for like being these crazy and unhinged
stalkers. It's people engaging in it who
weren't a part of our communities like
they or at least I'm trying to think
Dandras might have been kind of around
cuz he was a harmful opinions chatter
and harmful opinions had a lot of
overlap with Chloic. So Dandros might
have been like spicy chat at some point
but he wasn't in like our communities. I
didn't talk to Kandros for quite a
while. Y maybe I might have commented on
a Nux video. Definitely by the time he
got to the Mudahar engineer stuff, I
would say it is if I was to try to take
somebody's personal identifiable
information and publishing to the
internet so that they could be harassed
and or send it to a friend or use an alt
in order to get somebody digitally
harassed. I would want to know 100%
proof proof positive that the person
that I was attacking was guilty of the
crime. I would not do this like scorched
earth counterinsurgency
everybody who's resisting us that
Destiny and Dan are doing. I think it's
immoral. I think it's unethical. But see
like it's annoying because like Connor
is in there's some other part of his
brain that's engaged right now. But
especially if he was ever a cop like
this is absolutely
this is absolutely how you function in
the world. If you walk into a what a
trap he talked about like people getting
off from murder. He literally says that
he's had like dead to rights info that
doesn't meet the muster for proof,
right? But also, there's no tactic that
Destiny and Dan aren't using to prove
this. Like, you're not operating in the
same world. You're not even trying to
prove things to a reasonable doubt. I'm
saying show me the evidence of me
participating in this stuff ever. That's
what I'm saying.
You know what I mean?
It's totally crazy spot or whatever the
if you walk into some house and there's
like two dudes that are, you know,
trying with drugs on the table and
there's like four other people standing
in the um, you know, like the next room,
Connor would never be like, "Well, I see
we have two narcotics users here and
four of their friends must have stumbled
into here and I'm sure they have no idea
what's going on." You would never ever
ever ever ever make that assumption,
right? That's just never going to be the
case. If you stumble into a spot and
there's some going on and there's a
bunch of other people around that are
all friends with them that aren't
directly involved with the you assume
that they're all if they're not all in
involved in the they all know about it
and then it's generally like accepted in
that community you know I also think
that while there may not be fire like
we're not seeing the fire there is smoke
here effectively that the commentary
community is they use oent tools but
we've known this for years we just have
specific evidence of specific commentary
community members using open source
intelligence tools
Dude, just made the point. Is he going
to engage with that? That people in the
commentary community use those tools and
they have done for a long time to do
research and they handle this kind of
PII all the time. All of the people who
made Turkey to Tom's videos, all the
people who have made basically anybody
who does long-term research on anything
will know about these tools will do
these tools or sorry use these tools
rather not do the tools. Jesus, there's
no no response to that that you've
totally hung out with people who do
this. the the core way this is evaluated
is how safe how you know riskaverse are
you with letting that information get
exposed how well do you protect the
person whose information you might have
to look into these things right that's
that's the thing and obviously Dandr
Shimu have been very careful about that
as commentary YouTubers anyways so I
think we understand the dynamic but
Destiny and Dan unfortunately in my
opinion they're acting like they have a
headsh shot against Jot Queenman and
schizophrenic community members and I
don't think they do I think They have
smoke. They don't have fire. And so I
want to see fire. I want to see Jacock
or Queen interacting with doxing
information. I want to see schizophrenic
community members engaging with doxing
information. I want to see, you know, I
want to see more substantive evidence
that the specific people that they're
going off against uh are engaged in
doxing and PII gay ops. So like the
issue with this particular ask is that
like it's like saying like I'm not going
to arrest um I'm not going to go after I
don't know their names. the big drug
people, I don't know, some mafia boss
until I see him selling crack on the
street or whatever. And it's like the
people at the top top top don't have to
do that, but they know that it's
happening. They allow it to happen under
their watch. And then all of the
information that filters show that we
know it's happening. We allow it to
happen under our watch. Hold on. Hold
on. Show that. Show that we know that
it's happening. We allow it to happen
under our watch. Right? Like you could
Couldn't you just show that? You can't
say, "Well, these people, somebody like
lit a bag of on fire and put it outside
my door." And then go, "Well, because
that happened and this guy this guy's
always hated me. He he like spit at me
once at a football game. He's always
hated me. It's like a guy from your
church community, right? He's always
hated me." And I know it was him. And
the fact that he hates me and that he
says that he hates me to other people
proves that he put the on my door. No,
it doesn't. No, it doesn't.
videos, tweets or whatever else as a
result of that information. Then they go
on to directly amplify while claiming
well I ban that behavior in my community
in the public facing one like in a
statistical like Discord public facing
server. Um and then Hassan will amplify
that behavior on top of it. Right.
>> Assan's amplified doxing now. As
Hassan's amplifying doxing apparently
let me let me listen to this.
>> It's happening. They allow it to happen
under their watch.
>> We know that it's happening. They allow
it to happen under the watch. All of the
information that filters down into
videos, tweets, or whatever else
>> and all the information that filter the
the doxing information, right? There was
like doxing information that came
through. What's the information that
filters down into tweets and videos?
What is this
>> as a result of that information?
>> As a result of we we had to do we had to
find somebody's docs to get information.
I'm trying to think of like what example
this could come from, man. Like cuz I I
think Shimu's done some some foyer
requests, right, to find stuff for his
videos, but like that's not I didn't
help Shimu make his video.
Like I I wasn't involved, right? I
didn't even I don't even know if I knew
about Shimu before I saw the TechTone
videos. Like if I did, it would be
loosely interacting and maybe Spicy at
some point in the past. I'm like trying
to think of how I could even make this
make sense. I'm like trying to help him
prove his theory and I can't. I
literally can't. I'm trying. Then they
go on to directly amplify. That's the
funny thing. Gummy verse. Yes. Yes.
After the leaks, they amplified their
attacks. I don't even know if they
amplified their attacks. Gummy verse.
I'm not even joking.
There the doxing is way more before the
leaks happened. The the like doxing
stuff that's all way before or like a
huge chunk of it is way before. Like the
stuff that he was mad about, the stuff
that Aerodite referred to, that's before
the the what do you call the lawsuit.
Maybe not before the leaks. I can't
remember. or it's somewhere around but I
think Eerite has complained about
getting swatted between November and
January but in any case that's like when
the harassment was ramping up right it
was not it was not
something to do with me I was still you
know he was still coming on my streaming
while claiming well I ban that behavior
in my community in the public facing one
like in his like Discord public facing
server um and then Hassan will amplify
that behavior on top of it right
>> no you're arguing he would amplify the
stuff that flows down in the videos, but
then you have to argue what that is. You
do have to prove it. You can't just keep
gish galloping saying different. Well,
and so they find information. They'll
find like they'll dock somebody and then
and then but they won't publish anything
and they'll use whatever information
they found to find something out and
then that'll filter down into videos and
then Ham will publish that. It's like,
okay,
what is the harm that happened there?
What is the harm that happened?
>> And I mean, that's like a vibe thing.
don't really have uh don't really have
like the fire, but obviously I feel like
we have the smoke. So, this is only a
small part of the leak, too. Yep. I
agree with that. So, but that's where
reasons I want the bigger parts of the
leak, right? So, if there's something
that's more substantive that actually
does point to schizophrenic community
members engaged in P operations, then I
I want to see that. Conor, we agreed two
months ago that the only thing that
would convince you is DMs. Yeah, pretty
much. Pretty much. But, but hold on.
Hold on though. A fire rat. I want to
amend that statement though. It's not
that I don't think it's happening. I'm
not that naive. But if you're going to
convict someone or digitally harass
someone,
>> see, like this is like weird. Are we
using the Are we using like the criminal
conviction standard of beyond a
reasonable doubt here? Cuz you don't
apply this standard to any other spot of
your life, right?
>> Then I think you need solid proof,
positive evidence.
>> You You need some solid evidence. Yeah,
you absolutely need some solid evidence
if you're going to start doxing people.
Yes. Yep. Yep. Yep. You do need to know.
>> Be like,
>> you don't you don't need that for
anything. I don't know any YouTube video
that functions on like a beyond a
reasonable doubt basis to dox people.
You do if you're just going to say,
"Well, these people did something mean
to me and now I'm doxing them and
literally all you have is this." Oh, you
or Connor just total like schizophrenic
slob. Nothing. You got nothing to put
out. Yeah. You No, you need something.
You need You need to show it to people.
You at least need to be willing to show
it to people. Come on, man. This is your
this is your criminal conviction
standard of proof necessary for the
state to deprive you of constitutionally
due freedom. Like this is like for a
good reason. The highest like this is
such a high standard of proof that we
expect that some guilty people who have
actually committed a crime will walk
free. That's how high that standard of
proof is. That's such a weird thing to
call for in like these online
communities.
>> I shouldn't get to digitally harass you
through guilt by association. Right.
There's also another thing too that
these guys never seem to consider where
they say like well this is enough for
digital like all of this stuff is
perpetuated in a one-sided manner.
There's no world where if
Batman and all these and um Wicked
Supreme and all these [__] weirdo
losers if they like stop talking about
me where on stream every day we're like
oh guys did you see what happened here?
Oh guys did you see this? Oh did you see
that they got into fight? Blah blah
blah. Like why we just wouldn't we would
just stop talking about them right? And
even I would even go a step further. Um,
I'm not even saying that these people
should have to like they're never
allowed to comment on me or anything
ever anymore. It's like if they want to
do like political things or whatever
else or talk about how my political
things are or even if they want to talk
about my I guess like my No, I will talk
about your public facing content and
your conduct. Anything that's in the
public, I'll talk about
you. No, you Oh, here's actually what
you could talk about and I won't dox
you. you. No you
>> um drama for um whatever my
>> It's not one-sided latigious gamer. He
doesn't like basically this guy is like
Harvey Weinstein. If Harvey Weinstein
came up and went I didn't even do
anything. I wasn't even talking about
this. WHY IS THE NEW YORK Times talking
about my allegations? This is
harassment. No, no, no, no. Or TMZ.
Let's say TMZ cuz it' be more tabloid.
That's more on brand for us. Okay. We'd
be covering like little angles and
stuff. I'm sorry you don't get to start
doxing people. It's crazy.
>> [__] court case, whatever else. Then
fine, talk about whatever you want. But
it's the fact that you have become like
even if they want to talk about my I
guess like my um drama for um whatever
my court case, whatever else, then
>> wait, are we inventing a new standard?
Because that's I swear you just doxed
esports Batman on the pre him discussing
your court case. You just doxed him on
that.
>> Fine. talk about whatever you want, but
it's the fact that you have become like
an active participant in all of it that
is just so far beyond the pale.
>> An active participant in all of it. And
again, evidence, please.
It's just like so far beyond the pale.
And all of that is one-sided.
>> No, it's not. You've literally doxed
multiple people. You unbelievable
embarrassing.
What the is wrong with you? Um, actually
taking it to the next level is JUST ALL
ONE-SIDED BY YOU. IT IS ALL ONE-SIDED BY
YOU. WE'RE NOT DOING THAT AT ALL. WHAT
the is this guy talking about? Real
serious manifest will be your clean
break with all the drama, right? Well,
probably not. It like my core case
ending will be helpful for sure. Um, and
then in my manifesto, there are at least
a few people that I'm going to nuke for
sure. uh in an ideal world, yeah, I
wouldn't want to associate with any of
this, but the reality is is like these
people will always be functioning like
this unless something changes um until
like a strong there has to be a strong
centerleft thing that is built that can
withstand this. And I just don't know,
dude.
Liberalism might not be strong enough to
protect me from the outcome from the the
consequences of my actions. We need a
stronger liberal liberal movement that
can protect me from leaking multiple
videos of people without their consent.
We need a stronger liberal movement that
can do this.
I But uh holy I can't say what needs to
be said right now. I'm on Twitch,
but holy hell. Holy hell,
dude. Liberals just might not be strong
enough to get through me violating
multiple women's consent. Liberals
liberalism just might not be strong
enough to make it through this. They can
make it. It could make it through Trump,
but it can't make it through my crimes.
>> Bro, liberalism don't need you, little
bro.
>> Shut up. Who else is even capable of it?
Maybe Hutch, I think, is getting there.
Hutch.
>> He's uner He's unironically leading into
it. I am the only one who could stop
MAGA. I am the I am the only one who
could stop MAGA. You thought you could
stop MAGA without me. But you need Trump
grabbed them by the That was critical.
YOU DIDN'T REALIZE IT WAS CRITICAL. I
grabbed them by the by electronic means.
I publish women without their consent. I
record people. It's interactions without
their consent. And you didn't realize
you needed that, did you, Democrats? But
you do, dude. Actually, this is insane,
man. This is a totally insane
I I should stop getting shocked by this.
It shouldn't be shocking to me anymore,
should it? I feel like it shouldn't be
shocking at all. Which might be there.
Um I I don't know. I don't know who
else. Yeah,
>> Argentine is Michael. Like what I'm
talking about would have to be in the
order of like multiple massive content
creators that are aware of this and can
like very easily dispel it or talk about
it and be done with it rather than like
shy away from it, you know, in a
terrified manner. I also would like
those content creators to talk about
this. Yep. I would I would also like
those content creators to talk about it.
I would like them all to get informed. I
I think we can all agree. I would be
psyched if some people wanted to come in
and get informed on this. I'd be happy
for them to talk to Destiny and then
I'll talk to them and we could all have
like a back and forth on this. Yep. But
Hutch can seem to view things uh like
Connor and Wick. I don't think Hutch
ever both sides of the internet drama
stuff. He might I don't Hutch isn't both
sides anything.
>> Hutch just doesn't know. Hutch is too
egotistical. Hutch is egotistical enough
that he would rather ally with Destiny
than learn the truth. Right. That's
that's who Hutch is. We just disagree on
how far the Democratic party needs to go
coming into office. Hutch is probably
one of the only other strong liers who's
like, "We probably shouldn't be sucking
up to tankies all the time. They want to
destroy our movement. We probably
shouldn't be um giving a pass to people
who are engaged in like the crazy weird
Democratic Party assassination [__] that
like the far left like he's like the
only guy that does it. I think almost."
Fay, thank you for the gift to one sub.
Hutch. Hutch is almost ready to save
democracy, guys, because he just repeats
what I say one to one. Hutch is almost
strong enough to save democracy. He just
doesn't have the last thing that I have
that he doesn't. The the uncontrollable
desire to violate women's consents.
That's that's the only thing Hutch is
missing. If we could get Hutch to truly
turn to the dark side, we need his
Anakin moment where he cuts down all the
Padawan. Okay, it's Hutch being given
multiple videos that he knows are not
consented to to be distributed and him
tweeting them. Okay, that's his Anakin
moment. Once touch is there, you'll be
strong enough to defeat Maga.
>> I actually changed my opinion on this
when Destiny docks somebody merely for
discussing his case and threatened to
dox anybody in my Discord. If a much
larger creator is explicitly threatening
my friends and community, should I just
allow this? Breaking YouTube to in the
process if you're threatening us and not
just threatening us, but following
through on the threats, doxing threats,
taking things out of the digital realm
and putting them into the real life
realm intentionally, knowingly.
Now remember, the only thing that I'm
asking for these people to leave me the
[__] alone is to stop stalking, a
logging, and harassing every single
person in my personal life. You don't
care about them. When those people got
doxed, you didn't even want to let them
know. It's a totally fake thing. When
those people got doxed, you didn't care
to even let them know. Now, he may have
been convinced to let them know
by somebody else. I have no idea if he
if he on in July of or on July 24th, I
have no idea if he went and talked to
these people. Okay,
but he didn't care to go notify them
himself.
By the way, as soon as I stopped being
like super cringe all the time, as soon
as she stopped being like the most
cringeworthy human being ever, I stopped
reacting to her. Like, if she's just
fighting Republicans, I I don't react to
that content.
It's just It's weird. It's just weird
stuff, man. That's the only request I
have. Can you just like not like if you
want to talk about my again I showed the
clips of what this was. I've not been
going after like I react to people.
That's it. I just react man. I just
react. That's it. My political takes. If
you don't talk [__] about my or
whatever. If you my court case fine but
it's the this is not the standard. This
is not the standard. This is not what
you started doxing for. Relentless.
That's why he has to Oh, I see. This is
a new narrative shift, isn't it? So,
it's not that it's not that you can't
watch his stuff. It's or sorry, it's not
it's not that. It's that Kelly Jean was
talking about his girlfriend. Okay, I
totally Why? Why am I the target if
that's the problem,
>> right? I wasn't I wasn't talking [__]
about your girlfriend. I was actually
yelling at the person who's trying to
talk [__] about your girlfriend. That's
what I was doing. I was saying, "Don't
focus on other people. Don't go and
attack other people."
>> That's That's me. That's what I've been
saying. Who's confused?